let's talk about the seven foods that
will lower your bad cholesterol the LDL
but I really need to clarify this bad
cholesterol because there's so much
confusion every time I do my
um live show on Friday morning this
question comes up over and over and over
so I'm just going to do another video to
try to make it really really
simple and understandable so there's two
types of LDL but if we just take a step
back and just talk about cholesterol
when you get your blood profile and it
says your total cholesterol you have to
realize that they're not measuring this
cholesterol that's floating down your
bloodstream because cholesterol can't
float down the bloodstream because it's
all fat soluble it doesn't mix with
water
so when they say total cholesterol what
they really mean is all the cholesterol
in these different protein shuttles okay
and primarily I'm talking about HDL and
LVL there's other shuttles but let's
just keep this really simple so when you
see total cholesterol what you're really
seeing is you're just combining the
cholesterol in the LDL and the HDL
generally speaking and so when we talk
about HDL which is considered the good
cholesterol really what HDL is it's the
cholesterol going from the arteries or
the cells back to the liver
and the LDL which people say is bad is
going from the liver
to the cells or the arteries so this
next part I'm going to talk about is
really important because
if you see your LDL
very high okay you're going to probably
like be concerned but when you go to the
doctor and get your prescription to get
your cholesterol tested they nearly
always test LDL cholesterol okay they
don't check anything else related to LDL
and there are two different measurements
for LDL and this is really really
important to understand because
the real villain
on cholesterol and heart problems is a
very specific type of LDL and it relates
to a test that you would have to ask for
it's an advanced lipid profile test and
it stands for ldlp particle you're
looking at the number of particles and
the size of the particles okay
now what is a particle well like I said
before it's a carrier okay kind of
carries this cholesterol because it has
to have this protein little capsule to
transport it so there's two particle
sizes of LDL there is the large buoyant
version which is pattern a now buoyant
means it floats okay it floats to the
surface so it's these large fluffy
particles that are floating through the
bloodstream right they're carrying
cholesterol then you have the small
dense particles okay those are the small
ones that have the ability to penetrate
the inside of the artery because the
inside of the artery is just like one
cell thickness it's not very thick and
that's where you have the problem okay
that's the one that is pathogenic not
the large buoyant LDL it's the small
dense LDL that's the one you need to be
concerned about now a question I have
for you is which one do you think has
more cholesterol
if you guessed the large buoyant you are
correct so if you get your blood value
back and it says your LDL cholesterol is
high it doesn't tell you anything about
the particles of what type of particles
you have more of it mainly tells you how
much cholesterol in fact there's people
that have low LDL cholesterol and have
higher amounts of the small dense LVL
particle size and there are a lot of
people who have high LDL cholesterol and
have larger amounts of this large
buoyant pattern a type of LDL so anytime
you do your cholesterol be insistent
about getting this Advanced lipid
profile because it's so badly important
it'll give you the whole picture of
what's going on now let's talk a little
bit more about this small dense LDL okay
and you're going to see it as a small s
and a small D and then LDL on your blood
profile now the first thing you know is
you're going to see more of this profile
the small dense LDL when you have
metabolic syndrome when you have insulin
resistance when you have obesity when
you have diabetes you may also see this
pattern like I said before when you have
less or lowered amount of ldlc the
cholesterol which we're not evaluating
the particles we're just evaluating the
cholesterol inside of these particles
and the reason I'm trying to bring this
whole thing up is because there's so
much connection between cholesterol and
heart problems especially if you don't
understand these key points right here
you can be concerned atherogenic LDL is
the one that is the small dense version
okay that's the one that's involved in
glycation the word glycation basically
you're you're meshing a sugar with a
protein so you actually render that
protein
uh non-functional so it creates problems
with the proteins in your lining of your
arteries also this type of measurement
is involved with oxidation so that's
another Factor that's related to
inflammation free radical damage a
perfect storm for the invasion of
microbes and biofilms and plucking and a
whole Cascade of things but many times
in plaquing in your arteries you also
have these biofilms which are basically
microorganisms in certain calcium shells
and they tend to accumulate on these
rough edges in your arteries
caused by the oxidation or the
inflammation so small dense LDL is a
strong predictor by 3x of cardiovascular
disease now the other interesting thing
about this is that if you are on a
Statin drug
um your cholesterol will come down but
statin drugs don't reduce this small
dense LDL in fact they might increase it
all right so now the question comes down
to how do we lower
very specifically the real culprit the
real bad LDL the small dense version
well there are some foods that you can
eat that will help you I'm going to put
the research down below that validates
this each food I'm going to talk about
has a significant lowering effect on the
small dense LDL okay number one extra
virgin olive oil now you have to make
sure you get the real extra virgin olive
oil because there's so much fake stuff
out there but there is a really good
study that I'm going to put down below
that validates that now number two
avocados okay avocado can also reduce
your small dense LDL and then we have
fish oils I like to do cod liver oil but
you can use fish oils as well now the
omega-3 fatty acids that are doing this
you have both EPA and DHA apparently
it's the EPA that has this lowering
effect the next food is pistachios okay
pistachios can also lower this small
dense LDL then we have dark chocolate
okay and of course the one that I would
recommend men is the one that without
sugar and then we have almonds almonds
have a lowering effect on the small
dense lipoprotein and lastly walnuts can
also help you with your bad cholesterol
now there's a couple other really
interesting things about this topic
niacin the type of niacin that causes
that blushing response can very potently
switch from one particle size to the
other it can switch from the small dense
LDL to the large buoyant LDL that's
pretty cool and also has a moderate
lowering effect of your LDL cholesterol
itself next thing you could do is
exercise exercise will also lower this
small dense LDL and another thing will
help too if you have a really stubborn
problem and that would be Tut cut Tucka
is a very specific type of bile salt
that helps eliminate excess cholesterol
you have to realize the regulation of
cholesterol in the body is controlled by
bile salts in fact bile salts are made
from cholesterol and so if you are
deficient in bile let's say you have a
fatty liver or let's say you don't have
a gallbladder or just say that you've
been on bad foods that have made things
very very slow or sluggish within the
bile ducts that could be the reason why
your cholesterol is not coming down in
which case you want to start taking bile
salts especially for those that have a
genetic high cholesterol situation and
as a side note if you do have a genetic
problem with your cholesterol and you
want to do the ketogenic diet which I
highly recommend with fasting the thing
you want to do is not necessarily
completely go low fat you just want to
avoid the extra fat that a lot of people
take on the ketogenic diet which means
you don't want to take the extra MCT oil
you don't want to start consuming the
keto bomb treats filled with fat and
butter but you do want to increase the
fish oils and the fish that type of
thing because that is not going to
increase your problem and one last very
important point the worst thing to
consume would be sugar especially
fructose okay but sugar will tend to
worsen things for you and I'm also
including in that all the refined
carbohydrates as well now essentially on
the topic of LDL
I created a very interesting video
called the real reason why your arteries
are calcifying and turning into bone I
put it up right here check it out